[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous je suis guillaume roland
entraîneur dé 22 ans et inventeur en
effet du sein de san roque ici sur cette
photo j'avais 5 ans beaucoup beaucoup
d'idées en tête je voulais faire comme
les autres comme les plus grands donc là
en l'occurrence refusait la terrasse je
pense que tout le monde envie de faire
comme les plus grands on est plus jeune
voit ses parents on voit ses grands
parents ses grands frères ses grandes
soeurs voilà on a envie de emprunter la
chemise un chef d'entreprise de pouvoir
être pompier de pouvoir être agriculteur
entame on se projette quand on est jeune
et des fins quand j'avais vraiment envie
de faire comme les plus grands tout ça
ça a pu grandir à 10 ans je faisais mes
premiers bricolage
donc je démontais les voitures
électriques que j'avais à noël pour en
faire d'autres choses
à 13 ans je dépose mon premier brevet à
l'inpi ça m'a appris à à partir d'une
idée à déposer à écrire quelque chose
sur le papier à le protéger
et ensuite ce qu'a vraiment changé et la
première étape la plus importante ça a
été de sortir du garage
un concept qui était au départ sur le
papier et de pouvoir le mettre sur le
marché ce concept là c'est le centre
ouest le sang ne saurait que ce
prototype qui est née lorsque j'avais 18
ans dans le garage familial
c'est un réveil qui utilise des capsules
de parfums pour vous réveiller en
douceur
au départ c'était qu'un prototype les
parfums a été créé à partir d'un montage
à hydro destination je prenais des
feuilles de menthe de mon jardin je les
mettais une colonne que je chauffais je
recueillais l'huile essentielle
donc à partir de pas grand chose c'est à
dire d'une idée une feuille de papier
dans prototype avec des prototypage
rapide des solutions d'impression 3d un
poc ce qu'on peut appeler un proof of
concept c'est à dire une idéalisation a
pu être concrétisée et aujourd'hui le
sensor weck est présent en asie en
europe
c'est un produit qui se vend dans les
grandes surfaces dans plusieurs
centaines de magasins mais avant ça il
s'est passé beaucoup de choses
vous vous en doutez il ya énormément
d'étapes est ce que je voudrais évoquer
c'est que toutes ces étapes là au départ
elles sont faits plutôt en déconnexion
de ce qui peut se faire
traditionnellement pour marketing par
rapport aux ventes et après bien entendu
et tout une étape où la connexion a dû
se faire avec des partenaires externes
pour attaquer des marchés et pour
grossir mais avant cela
comment un produit dans un garage peut
arriver dans un marché peut être un fan
a qu'un darty un boulanger quelle étape
c'est la grande question qui lui était
posée au début
l'une des premières étapes ça a été de
se connecter à travers notamment des
concours et le premier concours qui a
permis à 100 de ses rêves de devenir ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui et doit avoir une
visibilité ça a été le google cn ce
faire le google soundsphere c'est chaque
année google qui sélectionne 15 projets
pour partir à mountain view dans leur
siège social en californie
quinze projets qui sélectionne partout
dans le monde ce but de ce concours
c'est de connecter les jeunes
innovateurs de faire régner entre eux et
pouvoir lancer des futurs start up
il ya une première sélection si appel
régional c'est par continent dont
j'étais déjà très étonné mettant sans
travail de pouvoir être sélectionnées et
j'ai eu la chance de faire partir des 15
à partir chez google et en étant le
premier projet français de cette
sélection là ça a été le top départ on
va dire de soundtrack belle aventure un
voyage déjà qui a été comme un rêve pour
moi
il mettait nos projets en grand sur les
building de google sur les vitres donc
c'est une sorte de rêve accompli un
premier rêve
et puis ça a été comme un intrigue
heures c'est-à-dire un tremplin pour me
dire guillaume tu vas 18 ans mais tu
peux peut-être faire quelque chose de
cette idée de ce prototype et ça a été
le cas je me suis connecté à travers des
moyens de prototypage rapide à travers
des tutoz sur internet parce que à 18
ans on a très peu de ressources à la
fois financières mais également en
connaissances et tous ces connexions que
le xxième siècle tout permis parce que
il ya 30 ans à 40 ans tout cela n'a pas
été possible nous permet de construire
un prototype et pouvoir le présenter à
google mais aussi demain à des
industriels et à des marchés
donc j'ai utilisé par exemple une carte
arduino
sont assez connus c'est des cartes qui
permette à des très jeunes de pouvoir
programmer et commander un produit et
pouvoir le développer
bien entendu utiliser l'impression 3d
qui est maintenant assez connue donc
impression 3d permet d'avoir une idée
une forme la mettre sur un ordinateur et
puis ensuite la concrétiser physiquement
à travers par exemple un dépôt de film
plastique qui créé un produit
et puis bien entendu d'autres méthodes
de prototypage rapide pour créer le
premier centre avec le présenter à
google et ensuite lancé mass start up
l'autre étape qui était très importante
c'était bien entendu des parfums c'était
impossible de pouvoir imaginer pour la
production faire des parfums dans les
labos de mon lycée comme ce que j'avais
pu faire au début avec les feuilles de
monde à mon jardin on va la faire
ailleurs appuyé une lente donc comment
faire pour créer cette premier parfum
encore une fois il faut se connecter et
là on s'est connecté au leader mondial
de l'industrie des parfums et des arômes
un groupe suisse qui s'appelle givaudan
pour créer des parfums pour le chausseur
wec et ça ça a été une étape importante
parce qu il a également fallu se
connecter à nos clients à nos futurs
consommateurs et comment se connecter à
nos futurs consommateurs
le plus simple c'est de leur demander et
donc on a lancé un mois après la
création de la start-up une plateforme
sur une plate forme de pré commande une
grande vente pendant 30 jours
donc on appelle ça le coin de phoning on
permet à des gens s'ils le souhaitent de
pré commander le produit et pendant 30
jours on a levé plus de 200 mille
dollars de près comment nous donc à
cette époque là on était 2 j'avais
moi-même et ivan qui m'accompagnent dans
le projet vraiment la vocation mais
aucune certitude
on a mis le produit sur internet et puis
en 30 jours 200 mille dollars de
précommandes qui nous ont permis d'avoir
les ambitions et de lancer le produit
sur le marché et on s'est connecté du
grâce à ces pré commande directement à
nos futurs clients à ces gens qui ont
reçu après le produit on leur a demandé
quel parfum quelles fonctionnalités et
donc ça nous a permis de faire un
produit et de lancer sur le marché
ensuite on s'est connecté à d'autres
industries une fois que le produit a été
lancé sur le marché
on s'est dit pourquoi ça a été un marché
particulier pourquoi pas un marché pour
les enfants s'est associé avec disney et
lexibook pour faire
un produit ça ne serait que pour les
enfants et ça ça a été une autre étape
on s'est connecté à d'autres entreprises
parce que plus ensemble
on peut aller plus loin et le produit
s'est donc ouvert à d'autres univers et
on sait également connecter à d'autres
marchés
parce que c'est important de ne pas bien
entendu penser qu'en france on peut
faire qu'un produit français mais qu'en
france on peut faire un produit qui
puisse aller à l'international
donc on a lancé en france au départ
aujourd'hui à travers des magasins
spécialisés dans 200 magasins en france
et on s'est lancé dans d'autres pays
donc là vous voyez par exemple deux
tours ça a été l'accueil assez
incroyable de 1,1 industriels
distributeurs chinois pour accueillir
100 de sovac donc qui aurait pu penser
que l'idée du garage un jour le centre
sans règles puissent être affichées sur
des building de plusieurs centaines de
mètres
en guise de bienvenue c'est une une
étape qui a été créé une ouverture une
connexion qui a été créé pour continuer
à développer le produit également une
connexion avec les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui et ce n'était pas le cas il
ya 25 ans 30 ans on peut avoir une idée
un garage on peut la mettre sur une
plateforme récolté deux des précommandes
la lancée et pouvoir la diffuser de
manière assez globale
donc on a pu faire parler de notre
produit par exemple aux états unis avec
jimmy fallon qui est un présentateur de
télé assez assez connu ellen degeneres
une présentatrice et puis l'idée du coup
a fait a fait écho et nous a permis
d'avoir les moyens de nos ambitions et
développer commercialement le produit et
tout ça encore une fois parce qu'on
s'est connecté parce qu'on s'est inscrit
et on a pu utiliser les réseaux qu'ils
sont à notre disposition que un jeune de
18 ans peu utilisé parce que ça
nécessite pas forcément les moyens
une campagne de pub d'affichage qui peut
coûter potentiellement plusieurs
millions eh bien peut être remplacé par
un communiqué de presse d'un produit qui
va être relayée par la presse américaine
ou à la presse européenne
et ça ça change tout ça ouvre des
possibilités google nous a continué à
nous suivre sur beaucoup de choses nous
a connecté notamment au monde entier
grâce au site e-commerce
on a pu faire du marketing digital c'est
à dire faire de la pub en ligne pour
vendre de produits pas qu en france mais
aussi à l'international
on a pu également communiquer sur
l'histoire de saint servais et de google
à travers des campagnes de pub
l'affichage que google nous a mis en
avant
et ça ça a été également une vraie
opportunité parce que se connecter à ses
clients en direct c'est bien mais
pouvoir recruter des nouveaux clients à
travers de la pub ou bien de la
communication ça permet d'avoir une
nouvelle clientèle ça permet de se
développer
mais tout ça c'est de la connexion on
sait également déconnecté alors comment
pourquoi et bien dans les premières
étapes
on s'est déconnecté pour aller plus vite
on s'est déconnecté des codes classiques
c'est-à-dire au lieu de faire une
marketing campaign une campagne
marketing de par exemple d'études de
marché qui peut coûter très cher on a au
début quand je dis dont j'étais seul
mais ça me permet de moins dire je au
début on a mis le produit quand notre
vie n'existait pas à travers une simple
image 3d qu'on a photographié qu'on a un
prix mais j'ai mis sur un packaging le
packaging est évident parce que le
produit n'existait pas et qui a été mis
dans les magasins et en fait ça nous a
permis de savoir si oui ou non les gens
allaient s'arrêter tester l'élasticité
du prix tester un titre une phrase
accrocheuse part bien entendu dès que la
personne ça a été prenez le produit on
les disait que c'était un test mais ça
nous a permis de faire une étude de
marché très rapide à faible coût et
d'avoir le meilleur retour client parce
que c'est des futurs clients kiwi ou non
demain achèteront votre produit ou pas
ça nous a permis de définir un prix de
avoir des retours sur le design tout ça
a été très bénéfique
c'est à l'encontre des codes classiques
c'est un peu ce qu'on pourrait appeler
une méthode succe la méthode d qui
caractérise beaucoup aussi les français
la débrouille
on a également utilisé ça pour plein
d'autres choses mais ça montre que quand
on est très jeune quand quelqu'un dans
son garage peut avoir une idée a une
ambition à pouvoir concrétiser cette
idée je pense que vous pouvez entre nous
aimerait un jour voir son produit dans
l'est dans les étals de magasins on se
pose souvent des barrières en disant
c'est pas possible il faut que j'aie une
campagne de
d'études de marché qui coûte ça que ça
coûtera sec cela mais finalement cette
déconnexion des codes classiques peut
permettre d'aller vite a peu de moyens
et de concrétiser son idée
enfin une autre connexion et je suis
content de pouvoir l'annoncer
aujourd'hui parce que la nouvelle a été
annoncée ce matin nous avons intégré le
groupe maisons berger paris la start up
sound strike a été racheté par maison
berger paris on s'est connecté un groupe
centenaire un groupe qui a 120 ans qui a
été créée en 1898 historiquement connue
pour la lampe berger un produit qui
parfume l'air donc une marque qui est
connu mondialement
dans les parfums d'intérieur pour
pouvoir porter toute l'aventuré ne
seraient qu il ya maintenant près de
quatre ans à l'international c'est une
opportunité de se connecter partout dans
le monde à travers des produits
innovants sur un marché qui est porteur
pour tout le temps amélioré soit le
bien-être conditions ça soit en france
aux états unis ou en asie
je suis content que cette aventure là
qui s'est fait au départ de manière
déconnecté dans un garage puisse
maintenant continuer au sein d'un groupe
mondialement connue avec une équipe et
je suis content de vous annoncer ce
merci
[Applaudissements]